it's a good [ __ ] feeling about you  mike sometimes i'm a little ashamed but  cause um  i know my shadow my shadow doesn't  deserve what my consciousness receives  so i look at it funny  wow i never thought about it when mike  say [ __ ] like that you just gotta just  look at him for a while just wait for  for it to die down and then be like yeah  all right that's what i'm telling you oh  that's really that's just guys though  you just make sure you're hearing but  i know that's right  or you go like  cool  right that way that way because if he's  not done he go  [ __ ]  your consciousness haunts you you know  your  shadow in your consciousness know they  haunt you it's what haunts you it wants  to make you afraid of succeeding